[Music]
yeah he went up that way like he was
headed toward 36
or brown wood or something
that is a wreck huh
dear lord that's super
muddy through here
put it in the call and i'll go check on
it
[Applause]
uh i'm not sure yet i'm way down here at
the back end of
smallwood road
you might want to head this way just in
case just code one's fine
you had a lot of static but i think you
should have that way i'm going to head
down
10-4 code 1 is fine
24-79
go ahead
the driver is going to be a white male
early 30s
with blue jeans
hello
officer bristol paris police department
um
do you know someone
do you know someone by the last name of
careco
i do you do yes uh-huh okay um
you wouldn't happen to pick anybody up
from 34th and clement over here would
you no i haven't no not anything i came
home and i went to bed
not a white male wearing all black
possibly bleeding from the head anything
like that no no no
okay yeah who do you know by the name of
carico
uh my boyfriend
okay
what does he normally drive
um it's like a gray ford somewhere
he called me about an hour ago saying
someone was bringing him home
but
where's he uh
i haven't seen him
no now i'm really scared
who who are you just talking to in there
if you don't mind me asking
my friend mary jane your friend mary jo
she was really sad about something and i
don't know why people call me about
their shit but they do so
you know okay yeah
well here's the thing what's your name
kayla kayla yes his name is kayla um
a truck that returns to
small wood road
um is turned over
in a
field right there at 34th and clement
where it turns back this way okay you
know
um it's turned over on its side
okay we were told
the witness says that looks like him
we were told
that what they're saying on the radio or
i was told before i left
the scene
okay okay yeah
and on the way over here
that a small little four-door car i was
actually told like a nissan sensor or
optima but an older model cameron no it
looks like her yeah
um no i came home about two hours ago
and i've been in bed i have to be at
work super early so i mean
last time i heard from him he was coming
home from somebody
okay
like he said somebody was bringing him
home is he okay
well we don't know we haven't found him
he walked off from the scene and we were
told that a small tan four-door car
yes ma'am gold gold contact with anybody
else
yes tinfoil
1061 real quick
uh stand by for a second um
with oklahoma license plates came and
picked him up i do have an oklahoma
license plate but i didn't go pick him
up you didn't pick him up at all no i
came home like two hours ago and i've
been
i have to be at work at like seven
o'clock in the morning and so
okay you might give me a second real
quick i'll be out of your hair here
shortly give me just one second
this is
not sure yet i haven't talked to him yet
she's really sweet i promise it's okay
[Applause]
hey mr colton can you come home out and
talk to me for a second
you tell me
please tell me
what's up hey mr colton
you all feeling all right
yeah you took a pretty nasty hit out
there good you did
you got any shoes on bob
can you get some on for me have you been
drinking any tonight at all
well somebody showed me
like this spirit
oh yeah
yeah i love the job
you mind getting them some shoes
for me i'm just going to have him step
out here to the front of my car
well now he's really mad at who he said
was taking him home because i don't know
where he went
what do i do about this
how can i help you i'm sorry how can i
i'm not placing him under arrest or
anything right now okay i want him to
know that i know i am going to get out
here i am going to get out of here due
to his slurred speech and his gloss red
glossy eyes i am going to get up here
and do sfs tv and that's the whole thing
is like
that's why he's really upset and the
truck returns to him it does i mean i
get that
and everything else yes of course it i
mean yeah that's the legality over there
we have first-hand eyewitness stuff i
witnessed
people
saying that
he is the only one that got out there
coco you're going to have to get up and
like are you you're staying i ain't been
driving my fucking truck somebody else
has been driving my truck i
how much have you had to drink today mr
colton
let me tell you something mr colton okay
and and this is i'm trying to be cool
with you okay i've been cool to your
girlfriend here all right i'm trying to
be cool with you okay you can either
answer my questions come outside and
halfway participate in what i need you
to do or
i can just take you to jail right now
and you not get any say in anything
okay comedian you you can quit being a
jackass to me because i'm trying to come
talk to you no no okay
called a dick or a jackass no one not
you not him no one does well i mean i
have showed up here tried to be in favor
okay correct thank you thank you for am
i wrong no no you're not wrong for doing
your job no and thank you for doing
him being a
lack of better words a smart ass to me
is not going to help him out in this
case no of course correct versus not
because he has caused damage to somebody
else's property but i mean we're not all
stupid and i don't think you're stupid
or he's stupid but
i mean he knows his rights i mean at
least somewhat and once he comes out
this door then that's when it gets
fucking weird and that's not gonna get
weird like i just sat here and explained
to you just like i said here
for me okay standard field sobriety test
all right okay it's not necessarily
saying that he's gonna go to jail that's
not saying that he's not gonna go to
jail i know but also if you refuse being
breathalyzed or anything then you still
go to jail we all know that we don't do
breathalyzers
but
i mean
no i don't think y'all are dicks or
anything he doesn't either he's very
sweet but he is very worried he doesn't
know what he was driving him he was like
will you take me home and then all of a
sudden
his car no
he's very personable
we're both musicians we're both fucking
little weirdos who just kind of stick to
ourselves i came home like i said two
hours ago
i got off work and like i had
one beer and i was like i'm going home
and then like he was like i don't know
what happened some dude was taking me
home
like i don't know where that dude's at
and so
what do you do with that but
okay what do you do with that though i
mean
because he wouldn't lie to me about that
i know that
going back to what you just said a
minute ago about
none of us are stupid here right correct
right yeah me and officer mccraw here
have done this for
a numerous amount of years okay i feel
like y'all are way more than i am though
but fair
we've done it for a little bit okay okay
and thank you i'm not sure thank you
because i could not i would want to
because
again i've been cool with you from the
get-go okay and i don't i don't mean to
sound like a jackass my wife tells me i
can come off that way
okay feel that way please don't do you
honestly expect us
to believe
that
mr colton does not know
who drove his very possibly i'm not
saying that he does or he doesn't but
very possibly
i just go to bed
no sir i'd like for you to come out and
talk to your truck is flipped and some
will give me something
no drop the gun drop the gun
[Music]
[Applause]
sit down
would you please take care of me
[Applause]
we'll get those
please get that out for me
thank you for taking that out
go ahead and sit go ahead and put your
feet in there are you taking me to jail
no right now we got more to worry about
right now like you're getting there that
we're trying to help
hey put your legs in there okay we'll
come back out here put your legs in
there
put your legs in there
my
kid
you need to put your legs in there or i
can put them in there for you
[Applause]
what is your name sir put your legs in
my body it'll all be in the report hey
my dad my dad was a state trooper
what's your next 30 years all right
good god
you're good yeah